Complete mediation actually comes about,
or we have that,
because of one other thing
the operating system does.
So at user level,
we have what we call virtual resources.
We don't have physical resources.
There is no way for
user code to actually name or be able to
target a physical resource, or
ask for a physical resource.
There you have only virtual resources,
and the operating system actually
gives you an API in how those
virtual resources can be used.
An example of this is that for
storing persistent data, we have file
abstraction, or virtual resource for
storing persistent data is a file.
So you don't access a disk lock.
The operating system does disk IO, and
schedule requests to read the blocks,
and services interrupts,
and things like that.
It can interact through
the disk controller.
Through those instructions
we're talking about.
But you cannot from user space.
You can only ask for
access to files either opening them or
reading them or writing them.
And things like that.
So at the user level,
we don't have ways of directly
talking to the disk controller,
the low level hardware functions
that operating system has access to.
We only have these virtual resources.
As a result of that, remember virtual
resources are what the name says.
They are not the real resources,
they have to be implemented
using physical resource.
The file has to be implemented
with a bunch of disc locks
where the file data is stored.
So the virtual resource has to be
translated to physical handles or
resources.
For example, buffers or
file data is stored on things like that.
And this translation is done,
from virtual to physical, implementation
is done by the operating system.
If you want to access a disc block or
a phase of memory,
you have to start with
either a file descriptor, or
you start with a logical address we're
talking about, or the virtual address.
And the translation from
virtual to physical
is the first step before you
can get to the physical.
Only the operating system
knows how to do that.
Or has the metadata, or has the control
information, that can be used for
this translation.
So this level of sort of indirection
that we add where you have
one kind of namespace and the underlying
resources have a different namespace.
And the translation can only be
done by the operating system, or
the trusted computing base.
Well that helps you get
complete mediation,
because you first need to go
have the translation done.
Okay, then you have to go to
the trusted computing base,
so the complete mediation gets
implemented right then and there,
because you're coming to it, and
asking for a physical resource.
So it could be the reference monitor.
It can check at that point,
that whatever that you are asking for,
do you have access to it?